este lunes el a británico adam pit y
demostró que es imbatible en los 100
metros braza el británico de 26 años
logró revalidar su título olímpico
conseguido en río en 2016 y bueno único
rey en el sugar en su categoría de estos
100 metros braza la que sí perdió su
corona fue que ayude aquí de eeuu que se
esperaba volviera a ganar medalla en los
400 metros libres pero fue destronada
por la australiana de 20 años ariadne
tiernos este martes bueno hay una tifón
el tifón de parta que se está acercando
a tokio ya japón y bueno habrá
seguramente algunos cambios en varias
competiciones entre ellas el surf ya que
en los cuartos semifinales y finales
estaban previstos para el miércoles pero
han sido adelantados para la mañana de
este martes aquí en japón estar muy
pendientes porque hay varios
latinoamericanos en liza entre ellos el
brasilero ítalo ferreira así como luca
mesinas de perú y bueno la noche de este
martes cerrará con algo que todos
estamos esperando y es
en ese concurso de gimnasia por equipos
ahí está la primera esperanza de medalla
de la estadounidense